all right are we rolling all right we're
rolling david hi
man how are you very well man all the
better for seeing you
dude spontaneously dude music to my to
my
ears and and synchronistic as well
because as i told you
we were just chatting uh actually me and
russ were just chatting about this this
concept of pivotal
mental states right states of plasticity
when you are receptive and ready to be
transformed
and these pivotal mental states are
characterized by increased
receptivity and reactivity to stimuli
both from
within and from without it's basically a
highly suggestible state
it's a vulnerable state because when
you're highly suggestible you could be
inspired
and you can also be manipulated right
it's a double-edged sword but
the point is trauma happens in pivotal
mental states but the inverse of trauma
which is transformation and growth and
healing also happens in pivotal mental
states so you approached me which was
was lovely and you said that my content
landed for you at a time in your life
that was that it catalyzed
or something was happening that landed
well with my content for yeah yeah i was
going through this great awakening
journey 2012 2013 2014
and your content around that time i
think i was saying that i was just
at this frequency where i thought
everything you were putting out like
every single week
i was watching it was just like tuning
me yeah lifting me up yeah
and just yeah massively promoting it's
opening me up and then it's funny it
like faded away
for a little bit in terms of like i saw
you but it kind of wasn't like
in that phase anymore and now and now
now we're here
now we're here and i saw your story and
then i was like oh my god i just saw
jason silver
and that's six unicity but you know it's
interesting because you speak about this
period like five
six years ago when the content landed
for you so
a constellation of variables converged
whatever was happening in your sort of
autobiographical life
your sense of self at the time your
psychological state like like
the specific context you were in for
whatever reason was a pivotal mental
state there was there was plasticity
you were hungry for transformation and
then you might have found anything
but through serendipity and or the
self-organizing
power of the universe you found my
content and
my content landed for you perhaps for
two reasons i like to think that
my content is evocative and powerful but
it's not going to land
unless you were in an open and receptive
state so you were in a pivotal mental
state
heightened plasticity ready to be
transformed and then my
content landed for you so it was a
perfect storm
in this case in your case it was a
perfect a perfect storm
of which we had no control right it just
a fluke it was luck
it was grace but what's interesting to
me is pivotal mental states or these
perfect storms they tend to be haphazard
right people have these moments in their
lives when they're open
ready to be changed and if they're lucky
enough that the right thing comes into
their field of awareness
wow i met that mentor at just the right
time or
i met this son of a that led me to
the to this cult that ended up ruining
my life
so pivotal mental states are you know we
have to be careful around them
nonetheless they are no longer these
half-hazard
perfect storms because the conditions
the precursors the underpinnings
of pivotal pivotal mental states are now
understood
jamie wheel and stephen cutler talk
about the four forces of ecstasy
psychology technology neurobiology and
pharmacology and the more we can
machinate and manipulate and dj and
calibrate
psychology technology neurobiology and
pharmacology the better we can engender
sentence setting environments where
subject
and object and process can become one
thing
in a pivotal mental state it's an open
heart surgery of the psyche
you're in a state of flow you're in a
state of heightened qualitative
intensity
you are ready for meta patterning to
take hold right programming and meta
programming the human operating system
but again
it's no longer a half hazard perfect
storm i can
create that perfect storm you can create
that perfect storm
and this is where breath work and other
techniques of ecstasy as
eliade refers to them as we become
stewards and masters of these techniques
of ecstasy as we become
ecstatic technicians of the sacred we
can program and meta-program ourselves
by opening up the floodgates of these
pivotal mental states right
parting of the seas and go in there and
do the work
not to mention once we do the work and
get ourselves back to
wholeness we can still deploy pivotal
mental states
for ecstatic play and creativity
my videos are forged
like the way you forge a sword in the
hot fire
right i forge my videos inside of
pivotal mental states
you know i'll i'll create a sentence
setting i'll create a
an environment that is safe and novel a
sacred space
and i might partake in a technique of
ecstasy of my own choice you know
cannabis is legal sometimes that plays a
role but
once you you have the the sentence
setting or the canvas
for the improvised performance piece of
consciousness which is what
david lenson calls it you basically can
arrange and rearrange the fragments of
perception that are coming in at every
moment
the place the people you're with they
all becomes part of your field of
awareness the music that's playing
so it's you're creating and perceiving
your world
simultaneously in a pivotal mental state
it's essentially a waking
dream like the film inception but when
you become aware that you're dreaming
now you can do the work so you engender
a sacred space
you enter the waking dream and then you
start to throw in
the music the song the mantra the topic
of conversation that naturally emerges
it's an improvised performance piece of
consciousness like a jazz
solo but the material is all of your
field of awareness
and i create that space and i forge
transformation and divination and
insight inside of those
pivotal mental spaces and then
afterwards i close the container
sometimes i record myself very much in
the container
sometimes i close the most pivotal part
and go to like part two
and then i record in the sort of
afterglow or the
or the or the or the integration session
that's also
good material because you're still open
but you're back to like
3d and so the lucidity and the coherence
is back you know sometimes when you're
in 5d it's hard to
find the words but the point is we
become
ecstatic technicians of the sacred the
art as shaman the jazz musician as
shaman who deploys the toolkit
to create pivotal mental states to
harness the power of creativity contend
with the unknown
bring something magnificent capture
lightning in a bottle
and simultaneously heal and then you
have something you can share with other
people
that can heal them in turn so that's
what we've been talking about today
and then i met you on the beach and the
opportunity to share this with you
has finally made it all come full circle
for
beautiful like the uber yeah that's like
true alchemy well you just deconstructed
that oh thanks bro
true alchemy well it's so good to meet
you how how's your heart how's your life
how's everything right now
it's very blessed to feel into them yeah
like this is
one of the few places left on earth yeah
yeah
everyone is gathered life feels abundant
the story feels open
it seems you look at it yeah i'm super
super happy i just can't believe i met
you man
yeah i mean look i i you're like you're
making young
crowds making you 90 90 years later
deconstructing young
new technologies and understanding we
have today thank you for saying that
that reminds me of timothy leary's quote
timothy leary says in the information
age you don't teach philosophy
you perform it amen and so again
performance improvisation a jazz
solo all of these things emerge
in a pivotal mental state so in the same
way that a pivotal mental
state can traumatize a pivotal mental
state can heal
but a pivotal mental state is also the
place from which creativity is
born and uh so again
in the information age you don't teach
philosophy you perform it
for me i unlearn and i relearn inside of
these pivotal mental states so thanks
for letting me share that with you
brother
and thank you guys for listening